Well, we're really happy that you came here today. you
know that you're part of a group of five individuals who
are participating in our genomics course. And we're here to
sort of spotlight your personal stories. And you've been selected and agreed
to participate with us because you have a very interesting
story and background. Because you are adopted. So what I'd like
for you to do if you can is just walk us
through a little bit. Tell us tell us where you're from.
What, what your name is? Where you're from? Where
you grew up? And you know when you found
out that you were adopted for the first time
and sort of how, how that made you feel?
>> Okay. I'm Sterling Tadlock and I grew
up in eastern North Carolina in a really
small rural community. About 50 minutes southeast of
Raleigh in a little town called Grantham. I
was raised as an only child, my dad was a sheriff's deputy, my mom was a
stay-at-home mom. we lived a pretty country, rural life. you
know, we never really traveled outside of the state. and I grew
up as an only child thinking my parents were my real parents which I still
classify them as my real parents but yeah,
I didn't really think, think anything about it until I got a little bit
older and sort of realized that, you know, I don't really look like my parents.
>> How old were you when that happened?
>> I was probably, you know, probably 11, 12, when
I sort of noticed, you know, my parents, have different body shapes than me,
I'm sort of tall, slender, they're not.
>> hmm.
>> And I always just sort of wondered, you know, why is
that? And sort of just put it to the back of my mind.
>> hmm.
>> Although I did notice that my friends, parents, and
their siblings looked more similar than I looked to my parents.
>> hmm.
>> But again, I didn't really question it,
because I didn't really think anything of it.
>> Did anyone else ever point that out to you?
>> You know, not that I remember I cannot, I can't remember
my parent, any one, any of my friends pointing that out. That I
looked a lot different than my parents. But, you know, there was
love and warmth in the family, and so. That sort of was secondary
>> Did you know of anyone else in
your family, extended or otherwise that had been adopted?
Or did you have any other kinds of interactions? Did you know
anyone else, either in or outside of your family that had been adopted?
>> actually I had a distant cousin that had.
been adopted by their grandparents. so, it
wasn't as far, you know, removed as I am from my real parents, biologically.
>> Sure.
>> but
that was really the only exposure I
had. I never really understood, you know, growing
up, what adopted meant, just because. Sex is
not talked about a lot in eastern North
Carolina and the understanding of you know.
Where you come from from your biological parents
wasn't really ever brought up, so the concept
of being adopted also was never brought up.
>> So, how old were you
when you finally actually sort of figured it
out or someone talked to you about it?
So it's a really investing story. I was 14 and like most people in eastern North
Carolina I was raised in the church. The
church was a big facet in everyone's life,
and I went to sunday school one day.
I was 14 and coincidentally it was father's day.
>> Hmm.
>> And,
in church that day, Sunday school lesson
the teacher was talking about how, whenever
you become adopted or whenever you become
a Christian, you become adopted into God's family.
And, he then looked at me then said, so, why don't you tell the class
what it feels like to be adopted, Sterling. And that sort of struck me
[LAUGH]
because I, I had never heard that I was
adopted before. Like I said, I thought that, you know.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I look a little bit different than
my parents and but then I saw pictures of
me as a baby with my parents and so. You know? I just thought about it. And I
was, like, no. I can't be adopted. And I
remember there was a, a girl, a distant cousin
of mine. Who said, Sterling's not adopted. those are
his real parents. And so, I sort of squashed
it in church. Although there was this rumbling anxiety within me.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then I went to the sermon portion of church. And I sat between
my grandmother, whom I refer to as MeMaw. And, my mama on the other side.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, I leaned over to my MeMaw, and I was
like, so, am I adopted? And she didn't look at me.
She looked, kept looking straight at the pulpit, and she's like,
you're going to have to ask your mother about that. and so
then I turned to my mama and I was like, so, I heard in Sunday school that I'm
adopted. And she's like well you are, and I
just sort of froze right there in the pew. And
[COUGH]
I just was in shock. I, I didn't really react at
first, and then I just started tearing up and crying and stood
up and just sort of left the church. We, I ran out
into the kitchen and. My mother and grandmother followed me in there.
>> What was going through your mind? Why, why, why were you upset?
What was, did you know what was making you upset about the time?
>>
It was mainly that, you know, my concept
of what, who my parents were, and their relatedness
to me. Was different than what I originally
had thought of, like they weren't my biological parents.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, then secondary to that, there, I
had biological parents out there that I didn't know.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, then along with that was the whole like,
me not knowing until the age of 14 like having
>> Sure.
>> This perception that, you know. The mother and father
that I grew up with were not my biological ones.
>> So did you feel instantaneously more distant
from them, or was this more of a.
>> It was a mixture, in that moment it was a mixture of shock, anxiety
sort of sadness I also felt. And felt this guilt,
that my reaction would in some way make my mother and father
that I grew up with, whom I refer to as my
real parents, them. I would make them sad by being sad,
which is something I think a lot of
adopted children go through. And it's a common
thing that I've had, like, emotionally, when I
sort of questioned who my biological parents are.
>> Mm-hm.
>> I think it's one of the, sort
of, disadvantages, in a way, of being adopted. Is,
this notion of survivor's guilt, where there's a big disaster,
this is where the term came from originally, I believe. There's
a big disaster, and those that survive the disaster feel
guilty because they're not the ones that have been injured or
killed. And when you're adopted, you feel like, I was
chosen you know, by my parents, but there are plenty of
other people who are still in the foster care system
who weren't adopted. And you feel like you should be grateful,
you know, that you were adopted. And you should
be thankful everyday that you live, that you have a
family that, you know, raised you and supported you, and,
and, I am thankful. But, you know anytime I question
being adopted. Who my biological parents are,
that's like a twinge of guilt, sort of.
>> It sounds like a lot of pressure
to sort of have to feel. Especially, initially, I'm
sure you end up dealing with it. Everyone
deals with it in their own way over time.
>> Yeah, and my own personal temperament probably plays
into it. Like I I, as you know, I'm a
psychiatrist and I sort of am really in touch,
or try to be with not only my own emotions,
but other people's. Like, that's sort of what I do as my livelihood is
help people who are dealing with a
lot of psychological stress. And pathology and.
>> hmm.
>> and so I'm sort of sensitive to
those sort of feelings of guilt and stress and
>> Sure, you mentioned that this was
sort of a disadvantage. You sort of discover
it and they're sort of this, this guilt you have to deal with, but can
you speak more about some of the other, are there any advantages
of being adopted and you know, is there, is there anything good that
comes from, sort of being in that scenario, did you find, where you
fortune, fortunate in any way or did you feel lucky in some sense?
>> I did, you know, probably, I don't know if it's
obvious or not but. Being adopted, you, you obviously were chosen
by two individuals, I guess it could be one, who want to raise
you, and, you know, who actively want to be, you to be a part of their lives,
and who want to, you know, surround you with their love, and their support and
their caring. Whereas not that biological parents
don't have that same feeling, but, sometimes you
know biological children just sort of happen I would imagine.
And there's not this rigorous active progress, process, not that.
You know, there's a very rigorous process in adopting an
individual and you know, in the fact that I was chosen.
>> Mm hmm.
>> And there's several other people who weren't you know, makes
me thankful that, that I was. obviously the advantage of being
able to be in a. Supportive, loving home.
>> Sure. How did that make you think
about your biological parents once you discovered this
information? What was going through your mind about,
you know, the scenario in which you found yourself?
>> Right.
>> Did you have a lot of questions?
>> Yeah, I mean, I think there's a lot
of fantasy that goes on with, you know, who
they could be, like are they like me? Do they act like me? Do they talk like me?
What are their professions? Like, what if it's
like, you know, I remember when I was a
teenager, like what if it's like some European like
royal family who like ships their child off to
North Carolina and was reared by, you know, some
really awesome southern parent. that obviously came to mind.
Also, like what if they're in jail or, you
know, you know, not even alive? Like, you know,
that, that came into mind. So I was just
always curious as to what they were, what they were
like. and also, what was the situation that led
them to having to put up a child for adoption?
>> Okay. so, what kind of questions do you have
now as an adult? how interested are you in, you
know, the, the idea that you're adopted and you know
you have biological family. You may or may not know or
think that they are alive or anywhere close by, but,
what kind of questions do you have about those ideas now?
>> About my biological parents?
>> Yeah.
>>
I still wonder like, what were the circumstances that
led them to, you know, you know, making the decision
to put me up for adoption. I'm also just
sort of curious about their lives, what are they like?
if I have any siblings or not, I mean, that's always
a question of mine. if there are any health considerations. You
know, there's a lot of health diseases, medical diseases have a
huge genetic component, and like, knowing that information is important to me,
And just sort of what their outlook on life is
now that they have an individual that's being raised by
other people. Like, do they ever think about me? Do
they ever wonder how I'm doing or what I'm up to?
>> Sure. What do you know about your actual adoption story?
Do you, you have any information about what actually did happen?
>> So after I found out I was
adopted, I sort of dropped, dropped it for awhile,
because I had this incredible sense of guilt that I should be thankful,
and I should be happy with what I have. And that I shouldn't, you
know, pursue things that may hurt my parents' feelings. so, I sort of
left it alone until I went to college. When I was in college, I
thought well I should, you know, try to
find out some information because it might be interesting
to know sort of, what information is out
there, knowing that it's probably limited. So I contacted
the department of social services in Wayne county,
and it took a month or two for me
to get these paper documents that basically set
the files close which means that the my biolo,
biological parents did not want to have
any communication with me after putting me up
for adoption. They wanted to sort of be a closed file, but they did have some
generic health information they entered in. And nothing about my biological
father. My biological mother was 19 she was in community college.
She really liked art she liked swimming, she was like
five four, had auburn hair. and it said that my, her great aunt
had breast cancer, I believe. And someone in the family had diabetes and
>> How did it make you feel to find that, even that little bit of information?
>> It, it you know just made me more curious.
because I know that there's so much more of a.
So many more facets of their story and their livelihood and
those are just few answers, and then hair color and height.
>> Sure.
>> And it made me more curious about what they were like.
>> Did you feel a connection to any
of the traits you discovered about your biological mom?
>> well, I have auburn hair.
[LAUGH]
That's sort of the closest thing. I guess I'm into
art somewhat, I like music, but. that's really it. It,
the document was sort of sterile in the information it
presented. So I didn't find that much of a connection.
>> Sure. Have you ever thought about trying
to, to find a, a, a bigger connection?
>> I have. you know The
other avenues that I could pursue to
find out who my biological parents are right
now all I've known about was perusing
the adoption detective agencies. I'm not really sure
what the formal name of them are. But they're quite expensive and I just have
never had the. The time or the financial
resources to to pursue that. but, I'm sort
of open to going through that avenue later on in life.
>> Sure, and of course, I know
because you're a, you're a medical doctor you're
a psychiatrist. You're familiar with what, you
know, modern technology can do as far as
DNA results. And, you know as part
of participation we've offered you an opportunity to
actually submit a DNA sample and find out
you know, if there, in the 23andMe program
if you might find any. Genetic relatives of
yours. What are your thoughts surrounding that? You've,
you've submitted your DNA, you've submitted your sample,
but you haven't seen your results yet. You
know what are some thoughts going into that
about participating in a program like that, and
what you expect to see, what you expect
to find, and how that might make you feel?
>> You know, to be honest, I haven't thought about
it too much. Because, again that fantasy
play of, you know, finding my biological parents,
like finding the DNA that may match with
mine and seeing what percentage the similarities are.
And, being able to contact them. I don't
want to disappoint myself, because I know that
the. The highest likelihood is that there's probably
going to be some distant, distant cousin that has
similar DNA to me. So, I'm not really putting a whole lot of stock into it
as far as finding somebody. But I am
interesting in seeing, you know, the other facets of
my DNA that 23andMe will sort of elucidate, such as risk
for medical diseases and pharmacological sort of
ability to metabolize drugs and to respond to them, I think that's a part of it.
And, just generic ancestry stuff, that's mainly what I'm looking
forward to seeing, but again, like, anything's possible, so. If, if something
were to come up it would shock me you know, and
I am sure I would have a, a variety of emotions.
but I haven't really thought about it too much. I am
going to like go through and sort of see what all
information is there I'm not sort of block it because if
it's there it's there and I want to know about it but.
>> Do you think in your current state of mind if
you were to find, let's say, you know, let's just say,
a cousin or more, you know? Third, second cousin or someone
even more related? Do you think you are interested in possibly making
a connection with that person and maybe reaching out
to explore more, and, and maybe even meet them.
>> That's a tough one. I, I'm not
sure. I don't know what all I would gain from
contacting someone that's any more further out than grandparents
or first cousins. Just because. You know, I'm worried
that it would opens doors to, I'm
actually not sure. I haven't really thought about
it, of trying to contact those people. I
think if it were like my biological parents
or siblings or grandparents, I would. But I
don't know because. They may not know, because it would
sort of open a doorway to possibly some drama where I
said, hey I'm an adopted individual and I'm your second
cousin and then they try to like contact all their relatives
to figure out who in their family's put someone up
for adoption. And that person may not want their whole family
to know that they had a kid and had to put
him up for adoption. I don't know if I want to expose
an unknown individual to that kind of sordid drama.
>> Sure. what,
do you know anything about any blood relatives
at all? Do you have other, so, besides
your mom, there's no knowledge, you don't know
of anyone else that you're genetically related to currently?
>> I don't know of anything substantial. There's always been
speculation in the community that, this person in a far
off part of North Carolina may be related to me
because they look similar to me or act similar to me
but, nothing substantial, as far as blood relatives. it would be
interesting if they were in North Carolina but I'm not sure.
>> And, sort of, just sort of wrap up pretty soon
here. let's say you participate in 23andMe and you do find
something and it's closer, you may find a relative that's closer
than second cousin, you may have whatever feelings you have about it.
what are your thoughts around your adopted family, your,
as you call them your real parents What do you
think, how do you think they feel about this or
you connecting, or just what are your feelings surrounding that?
>> I feel a little bit better about,
when, since, since the first time that I found
I was adopted to this current point in time,
we've talked about it here and there. And they've
sorted of openly admitted they would be fine with
me going out trying to find my biological parents,
they said if they were in my position they
would want to know. You know, if there was
someone that was biologically related to them, they said that that curiosity is
something that they don't think they could sort of push, push aside.
and they don't feel you know at all, like they're less
appreciated for what they've done for me or
feel like I love them any less. which
I don't because they did raise me. So,
but you know, there's always going to be a tinge
of that sort of survivor guilt or whatever.
that I'm always going to have. But I don't think
it'll impede me from trying to contact. Or,
pursue some sort of connection, if there is one.
>> Are
you excited to see your 23andMe resuts?
>> I am, I am. I've been holding out, they've
actually been available for a little bit now, but, for the
purposes of the interview I've, sort of held back. I'm waiting
on the edge of my seat to see what they say.
>>
[LAUGH]
Well, I hope that they're good results, no matter what
that may be, and. We'll see what kinds of, you
know, feelings and emotions, and where you are, we'll give
you a chance to look at those results and see what
they are and we'll let you come back hopefully and
talk to us a bit about what you found out. And
at the very least, you know, we'll talk about deep
ancestry and lineages, some of the health risks, but also hopefully,
maybe even some relative connections.
>> We'll see. We'll see, I'll stay hopeful